Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Das war's für heute.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
So, da bin ich.
Patrick, danke für den Sub.
75 Jahre, krass.
Alter, sag schon.
Älter als ich mittlerweile.
Ich mache jetzt mal hier gerade noch mal aus.
Wir flashen das Ding gerade noch mal, dass wir den gleichen Stand haben von vorher.
Oh, wo habe ich denn mein USB-C Kabel?
Äh, Keg Wait.
Ach hier.
Danke für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions, danke Leute.
Heute High Performer C++ Mindset heißt im Endeffekt wir müssen, ob wir wollen oder
nicht, müssen wir durch.
Egal wie scheiße C++ ist
Wir müssen durch, Leute
Sigma-Programmer
Heute wird sich nicht gedrückt
Heute wird dieses komische Display zum Laufen gebracht
Kek-Business, genau
Und dann kommt ihr alle in die C++-Gruppe
Flaschen wir jetzt nochmal?
Ähm.
Flash Champ.
Video Capture.
Da sind wir.
Ding ist an.
Und ihr seht, das macht immer noch das gleiche, wie das letzte Mal.
Ne? Seht ihr?
Macht immer noch das gleiche, wie das letzte Mal.
Also das Display, erkennt man's,
das Display geht,
geht, ähm,
leicht an und wieder aus.
Erkennt ihr, oder?
So, es geht leicht, leicht an, dann geht es wieder aus.
Das ist das Einzige, was wir das letzte Mal hinbekommen haben.
Und heute probieren wir das, irgendwas anzuzahlen.
Genau, das Backlight vom Display geht an.
Wir bekommen das heute hin.
Ich habe nämlich ein Beispielprojekt gefunden.
Wäre, wo ich, nachdem ich gesucht habe, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das hier schon einmal offen hatte.
nämlich habe ich dieses beispiel projekt gefunden und das sei ich ganz vielversprechend aus da
gucken wir uns jetzt einfach ab wie das ganze funktioniert und wenn das display dann funktioniert
dann gucken wir auch dass wir was darauf anzeigen können wir machen dann einfach mal also ich weiß
jetzt schon dass es richtig paint champ werden wird erstens steinadler danke für den zap erstens
wird es richtig painstamp werden, dieses Display
überhaupt zum Laufen zu bekommen, weil das haben wir das letzte Mal
nicht hingekriegt. Und was als nächstes
wahrscheinlich, also das habe ich schon so im Gefühl,
auch extrem painstamp
wird, weil das Problem hatte ich mit dem alten
T-Display, dass man die
Farben richtig anzeigt.
Da müssen wir
dann mal schauen.
Ich muss erstmal
ordentlich was trinken.
Ich war heute in Frankfurt vor Ort.
Irgendwie, wenn ich im Büro bin, trinke ich irgendwie immer zu wenig.
Aber danke schön für den Zapfstein, Alter.
Pogu.
Also Leute, das wird heute wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so easy.
Wobei, High-Performance-Crimeset-Mindset.
Alles ist easy, wenn man nur an sich selbst glaubt.
Also.
findest du eigentlich esp home ich habe erst die hauptkurs hat ich verwendet ich
habe immer eigene firma gebastelt für die sachen die ich machen wollte mit mit
microcontroller ich habe esp home hatte ich war ein paar kleine sachen
gebastelt aber einfach richtig machen gleich easy
Wir schauen mal, wo wir stehen geblieben sind das letzte Mal.
Also.
Das können wir mal wegmachen.
Das können wir auch wegmachen.
Also.
Wir, was machen wir dann hier?
Wir schalten.
Die Power vom Display an.
Wir setzen aus irgendwelchen Gründen
zweimal das Backlight auf...
Ne, hä? Das brauchen wir gar nicht.
Wir setzen irgendwie diesen komischen LCD-RD-Pin auf Output und auf High.
Warum auch immer.
Weil, das habe ich im Beispiel gefunden.
Mal gucken, was machen wir denn sonst noch?
Wir legen hier irgendwelche Magic-Sachen an.
Noch mehr Magic Sachen, die angelegt werden
Und weitere Magic Sachen, die angelegt werden
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir das mit dem anderen Beispiel ein bisschen besser hin
Was da was eigentlich ist
Twitch lügt
Das stimmt, du warst mehr als dreimal da
Sie baitet dich
Das ist Ragebait
Das Twitch schreibt dir absichtlich was Falsches
Dass du es berichtigst im Chat
Das ist eigentlich absolut High IQ Next Level
Von Twitch
Heute Giga Chat Programming
Nur so
ist das auszuhalten mit C++.
Welches ESP-Modul ist das?
Das ist ein ESP32S3.
Kein T3.
Das ist ein...
Das da ist das. Guck.
Ein LilyGo T-Display S3.
Das ist ein ESP32S3
mit einem 1,9
Zoll
LCD-Display.
Wohlgemerkt, nicht einfach so ein popliges LCD-Display,
sondern ein
OLED-Display?
War das nicht sogar?
Nee, oder auch nicht.
Hat zumindest ganz viele Farben und ganz toll.
Und was richtig cool ist,
übrigens eigentlich richtig
nice, ne?
Version
Blackshell. Du kriegst für 13
Dollar, kriegst du dieses komplette Ding
mit
einem fertigen Case aus China.
Finde ich, ist eine richtig gute
Grundlage für ein Projekt.
Crysis?
Also, jetzt, ich weiß,
dass das ein Witz ist, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft,
von der Performance her,
nicht Crysis,
aber sachen
aber so inklusive quake 3 würde ich sagen müssten rein von der performance her gehen
natürlich gibt sie da nicht für ja aber von der performance würde ich sagen moment es ist
ein S3. Ein S3, der hat ja nur
eine CPU, glaube.
Aber selbst dann soll es das hinhauen.
Das ist auch von den Specs her richtig nice.
Das Ding hat
Low Energy Bluetooth,
WiFi.
Oh, das ist der
neue Dual-Core der S3. Ich habe nichts
gesagt.
240 MHz Dual-Core.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch 240 MHz
Dual-Core ist.
weiß nicht was das dabei ist, wollen wir mal gucken
schauen wir mal
lass mal schauen
was da für ein
Moment
die wollen allen Ernstes
dass ich bei ihnen nichts kaufe
weil ich einen Adblocker anhab oder was
dann kaufe ich da halt nichts
hier ich will einfach nur gucken wie viel mega hat die cpu hat
sieht man das irgendwo
megaherz also echt fertig machen
240 megaherz 240 mega als sulcor das ist sehr nice für so was kleines also ich finde das top
und ich weiß nicht wie die China Chinesen das machen
Chat
mal blöde Frage
soll ich einen ordentlichen Streamtitel machen und diesen Blödsinn drin stehen lassen
nicht dass ich die Leute abschrecke
weil es geht hier nicht darum in die Gruppe zu kommen
ich habe mich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen in geistige Umnachtung
befunden
stimmt
man muss einfach nur an den Erfolg glauben
habe ich vergessen
Ihr werdet reich an Knowledge, Leute
Und ich auch
Big Brain
IQ
Also ich frag mich ja, wie die Chinesen das machen, ehrlich gesagt
Für 13 Dollar so ein komplettes Ding anbieten
Man darf nicht vergessen, das hat glaube ich sogar 8 MB RAM.
Kann das sein?
Ah ne, sorry.
Doch, guck mal.
16 MB Flash und 8 MB RAM.
Das ist ziemlich pog.
Für so ein kleines Ding.
Das lacht jeden Raspberry Pi Pico aus.
Verstehe nicht, warum Leute einen Raspberry Pi Pico nehmen, ehrlich gesagt.
rein vielleicht vielleicht rein für stromverbrauch weiß ich ob da viel viel besser ist könnte sein
für batteriebetriebene sachen eventuell da bin ich mir nicht sicher aber ansonsten wüsste ich
echt nicht was von der spielspiel spricht ja also das ist das board und ich dachte wir gucken uns
mal dieses beispiel hier an weil ich finde ich mach mal kurz diesen ganzen krempe ging das noch
mal close all left gab es noch nicht so was
close tabs to left bam 5 mal all tabs to so muss das sein
ne du hast dein piehole sicherlich nicht auf dem raspberry pi pico du hast die
vielleicht auf dem Raspberry Pi Zero oder auf dem normalen Raspberry Pi, aber Pico ist
der Microcontroller Raspberry Pi, der mit dem eigentlichen Raspberry Pi gar nichts zu tun hat.
Du musst ja erst mal mehr RAM downloaden. Den Link findest du auch in der Gruppe.
0 ist normaler raspberry pi in anfang normal mit linux und allem drauf aber die picos
dass der microcontroller also ohne linux ja ja ja die dinge taugen die verstehe ich warum
man die benutzt man vollständiges linux haben will raspberry pi 0 vollkommen in ordnung
Das ist vollkommen top hier.
Das habe ich auch hier am Start.
Zum Beispiel eine Raspberry Pi Zero Kamera.
Und da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Das Ding widersteht seit drei oder vier Jahren Wind und Wetter.
Ich hab das in so einem Silikonschlauch und hängt im Hof.
Ich tausche den Streamtitel.
Ich drehe das doch um.
Das ist mir sogar selbst zu blöd, dieser Streamtitel.
Ja und, was hast du davon?
Ja, das würde mich auch interessieren.
Das würde mich auch interessieren
Das ist doch eine ganz normale CPU
Ohne irgendwelche
Hardware Schaltung Sachen
Leute ich habe noch einen ganz alten Raspberry Pi Zero
Der hatte glaube ich nur
Was hat denn der
Was hat denn der erste Raspberry Pi Zero
Wifi gehabt
64 MB oder irgendwas RAM?
Der hat fast nix.
High, Zero,
äh,
B.
Was hat, ja, der ganz normale.
Was hat denn der?
Moment, der hatte schon 512 MB RAM?
Wirklich?
So viel hatte der damals schon?
Damals war RAM billig, hä?
Ach shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
Nein, ich habe den allerersten Raspberry Pi Zero gesucht.
Ich dachte, der hatte deutlich weniger RAM als hier.
Aber da hat es tatsächlich 512.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Eigentlich gedacht, es war weniger.
So, jetzt erstmal kurz
OS-Update.
Eigentlich soll man Minus S nicht benutzen,
habe ich mal irgendwo gelesen. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ah, geil. Invalid Option. Kack, weh.
Die Dinger sind scheiße teuer geworden.
Ja, seit ein paar Jahren ist Raspberry Pi
nicht mehr so geil.
Die waren ja auch teilweise gar nicht zu bekommen.
Du hast ja teilweise gar kein Raspberry Pi bekommen.
Reboot.
Warte mal.
Nix.
Near Chatbrains Toolbox.
Okay.
Reboot.
Bam.
Was kosten aktuellen Raspberry Pi 5?
Das ist doch noch der aktuelle, oder?
Ich wollte eigentlich Amazon eingeben, aber
zum Glück checkt er das
immer noch.
Ich weiß, bei Amazon
gucken ist nicht das Allerschlauste.
Alter!
Ja, diese Sets sind ja immer übelst
Setsche-Bait.
Barry Bays
Warte gucken
Der Maker Shop
Pai 5
Boah
Die Dinger sind aber echt schweineteuer geworden
Du kriegst für 122 Euro
Du kriegst fast schon einen kleinen Mini-PC
Oder was heißt
Du kriegst auf jeden Fall einen Mini-PC.
Kein top aktuellen Mini-PC, aber du kriegst schon einen Mini-PC.
Der braucht zwar ein bisschen mehr Strom,
wobei der Raspberry Pi 5 unter Volllast auch ordentlich braucht.
Aber Volllast haben die Dinger ja nicht.
Braucht ein bisschen mehr Strom,
aber hat sicherlich auch noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob sich...
Ich meine, okay, es bietet sich immer noch dann an,
wenn man GPIOs und sowas braucht.
Dann ist klar, dann kommst du am Raspberry Pi nicht vorbei.
also wenn du linux system haben willst mit mit gps möglichst viel ökosystem oder distribution
die super unterstützt werden alles da ist es ist ja nicht von der hardware so das einzig
wahre so sondern da gibt es noch andere aber das gesamte ökosystem und den raspberry pi ist halt
so gut da kommt halt wenig mit das heißt wenn man die pi ausbraucht und alles was der us-preis hat
auch die Kameraanschlüsse und so Zeug,
dann ist es natürlich
immer noch nice, aber ansonsten,
wenn man darauf einfach nur ein paar Sachen laufen lassen
will, Linux-mäßig, ja,
dann kann man sich doch auch einfach einen gebrauchten
oder einen neuen, bisschen älteren
Mini-PC kaufen
für den Preis.
Du bekommst einen Mini-PC für den Preis.
Klar, gibt's doch immer wieder
diese Dinger bei AliExpress
für 100,
reich nicht 100 120 euro mit mit einem alten die o-troy dinger sind wirklich
nice da hatte ich auch mal einen im einsatz
sie sah fast so aus wie der aber das auch teuer
ja es ist halt auch teuer aber da dürfte ein bisschen mehr power haben dann das
sind doch immer genau sind sie rock chip dinger ich hatte mal eins von denen ich
Ich hatte mal eine O-Droid H2, glaube ich.
Da war eine Festplatte dran.
Aber die gibt es nicht mehr.
O-Droid H2.
Ne, das hatte ich nicht.
HC?
Das da!
Hatte ich, genau.
So ein Teil.
Da konntest du eine Festplatte, das war auch hier
quasi Single-Platinen-Computer,
da konntest du hier eine Festplatte dran machen.
Das war eigentlich ganz nice.
Hatte ich schon eine ganze Weile
als TV-Head-End-Server im Einsatz.
Wir gucken mal bei
AliExpress kurz, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
So, Kessler hat rebooted.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was für Mini-PCs man da
sucht, also
Also, betrachte das mal mit einer Portion Skepsis.
Oh, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, jetzt habe ich die ganzen Tabs wieder aufgemacht.
Wollte ich doch gar nicht.
MonkaS.
Okay, Close Tabs.
To the right.
Bam.
AliExpress.
Minipi.
es ist ja mal gut es ist gut aliexpress
die wollen sie aber wissen
guck hier leute sagt jede menge kriegst du da du kriegst teilweise richtig gute
mit vier ethernet ports und sowas muss man sich mal gibt es ja auch
mittlerweile viele Channels auf YouTube,
die sich damit beschäftigen.
Und die Dinger testen. Also da gibt es jede Menge
für so um diesen Preispunkt.
100 bis 150 Euro.
Das ist auch
bestimmt Gute.
Ne, das braucht man nicht in jedem Projekt.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich für viele Sachen sinnvoller
als in Raspberry Pi 5
für das gleiche Geld.
Das Power Supply, ja das suckt.
Ich hab auch, ich hab auch ein Minis Forum.
Ich hab auch ein Minis Forum PC.
Einen hab ich meinem Vater geschenkt, da hat er den benutzt jetzt mit Linux Mint und einer,
steht hier direkt unter dem micro controller da steht der mic also da
steht dort wo der micro controller liegt und das handy drauf legt das ist auf dem
mini pc man sieht es jetzt nicht aber direkt hier unten ist das so direkt hier
unten so an der kante
genau der jetzt wird ja auch noch eine ganze ecke teurer als bei die palme
zubehör so sieht's aus so high performance c++ mindset leute sea lion starten
heute überreden wir das display zum funktionieren
zack cd repos qr code champ export ja ich weiß die zeit ist nicht so dolle zum stream 17 uhr
sind leute gerade auf dem heimweg oder irgendwie gerade am abendessen oder so aber ich muss dann
um spätestens 19 uhr 1930 irgendwie so muss ich mich vom acker machen deswegen bin ich so früh
am Start.
So.
Also, auf geht's.
Chatge.
So, wir schauen uns
jetzt mal hier dieses Beispielprojekt
an, weil ich finde, das sah
so aus,
ich glaube, hier musste man gucken,
das sah so aus, als weiß der Typ, was
er macht. Das heißt, hier können wir uns auf jeden Fall
schon mal irgendwie...
Das ist ja auch Arduino-Code. Warum?
ok das kriege ich aber in esp edf übersetzt also hier lcd power high machen wir rd output
high machen wir auch so dann geht es weiter wir kopieren uns jetzt
Wo hat er seine Pins definiert?
Wahrscheinlich Display H.
Display H?
Ne.
Wo hat denn der Dude die Pins definiert?
Konfig H bestimmt.
Konfig H.
Ja.
Ich kopiere mir das einfach mal.
Da kann ich nämlich auch mehr
aus dem Beispiel Copy Pasten.
so machen wir das mal sagt pin button 1 brauche ich nicht battery brauche ich nicht batterie 2
reset power backlight ok auch nie jetzt müssen wir wieder so machen hier eine
GPIO 5, weil das sonst wieder rumspackt. GPIO 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 15, in der Hoffnung es gibt alle GPIOs, 38, 39, 40,
jetzt kopieren wir das nochmal, sag 41, 42, 45, 46, 47, 48, okay, so, wie geht's denn jetzt los, also erstmal hier diese ganzen Krempel inkluden, LCD, Panel, Ops und sonst was, gut, machen wir, schmeiß ich den Kram, den ich hier schon mal reingemacht hab, wieder raus,
raus, raus,
raus, das kommt rein.
Und was hat er in Display H?
Importiert er da auch noch ein paar Sachen?
Das, okay.
So.
Aber erstmal alles included.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, wie es losgeht.
Das heißt nicht Pin Power, sondern Pin
LCD Power.
Gut.
Pin LCD RD heißt immer noch so.
Also, wie geht's
denn los?
Das ist doch mehr oder weniger das gleiche was wir auch haben. Aber ich kopiere das aus dem Beispiel.
LCD Pixels Width. Das können wir uns auch kopieren. Ich habe das gleiche Display,
ich habe den gleichen Controller. So, Reformat.
Passt das?
Chat, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Meint ihr, wir kriegen es heute hin mit dem Display?
Ich weiß, das ist nicht das High-Performer-Crimeset-Mindset an sich zu zweifeln, aber das letzte Mal war ja echt größerer Akt.
Meint ihr, glaubt ihr, das klappt heute?
Ich hoffe mal.
C++ besiegt uns.
Bis 19 Uhr, maximal 19.30 Uhr.
Chat-GPT, ja, Chat-GPT werden wir fragen.
Meinst du, es klappt nicht bis 19 Uhr?
Moin, Fanatics.
Du meinst, es ist eine T-Shirt-Größe M?
Ja, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall im nächsten Sprintplanning und in der Retrospektive mal gucken.
Mit Wim, aber nur, wenn die Finger immer auf der Home-Row sind, sonst geht da gar nichts.
So, Moment, ich schmeiß, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich schmeiß diesen ganzen anderen Krempel mal kurz weg.
den ich hier hinzu...
Das lassen wir. Das brauche ich, um
das Backlight anzumachen.
Wir lagern das mal aus.
Pin, LCD,
Backlight. So.
Dieses Gedöns mache ich raus. Ich sage einfach,
dass das 255
volle Pulle
leuchten soll. So.
Dann machen wir mal kurz hier noch sowas hier an.
Void.
Tja.
Activate.
Backlight.
Zack.
Wo heißt das jetzt?
Und da packen wir diesen
Krempel rein und sagen dann hier unten, weil sonst
blickt man nicht mal durch.
Activate Backlight.
Also wenn die IDE mitdenkt,
dann tippt man manchmal Mist.
So, perfekt.
Also.
Hätten wir das.
Wie geht's weiter?
so okay wir machen das einfach mal wie im beispiel m bus händel gibt es nicht wo es m bus händel m
bus händel bestimmt im display punkt h da kopieren wir den kram
es geht es nicht darum wie gesagt nicht darum das schön zu machen sondern dass
das display irgendwas ausspuckt irgendwas und wenn es so random pixel sind so
das transfer dann macht er da überhaupt irgendwas der macht doch hier drin gar
nichts oder m on transfer dann ist der tag ist der kaste das dann wird heute falls
ich brauche wahrscheinlich gar nicht gucken wir mal weiß ich wofür das gut ist
user ach so der übergibt okay keine 0.1 haben wir das letzte mal das gleiche problem schon
null point und jetzt klauen wir uns einfach mal diese methoden signatur hier machen da ein land
war draus und zwar wieder c++ und es funktioniert natürlich nicht diese syntax ist so rot will er
denn ok c++ fehlermeldung cannot elise leis i o config of teil bla bla bla west priest in
liste in installation fällt hier unten steht hier unten steht different return
types void and pool jetzt mal eine blöde frage warum schreibt man nicht einfach
das hin und lässt diesen üblichen schritt weg der absolut nichts sagen
unsinnig ist also sagen wir hier was was mit der
vor falls return der typ jetzt machen wir doch mit turnfels glaubt das ist der sinn
der sinnvollste callback aller zeiten mit callback und return falls instant
werden das ticket besser schneiden müssen ja ich hatte heute sprint
retrospektive und sprint review und sprint planning alles hintereinander
so was von agil gesprintet wurde da jetzt brauchen wir das da im bus händel und jetzt kommt was neues
das hatten das letzte mal nicht was ist das was ist das die weiß config reset gpio nummer okay
Hammer Colour Space ESP LCD Colour Space RGB und 16 Bits pro Pixel. Das heißt wir haben eine ziemlich
hohe Farbtiefe nennt sich das. So dann machen wir alles das und aktivieren das Backlight. Okay,
dann schauen wir doch mal was jetzt passiert. Flash, Bäm, Chat was meint ihr? Schnell,
bevor man sieht was meinte geht es oder geht es nicht 321 zu spät es riecht sich endlos
warum
aber weil ich riesen unten drin stehen habe lehrer acht problemen
Eindeutig Layer 8 Problem
Was will der eigentlich hier?
Okay, keine Ahnung
Und es geht nicht
Okay, besser gesagt
Ich weiß ja gar nicht, ob es geht
Wir malen ja nichts auf das Display
Wir müssen irgendwas auf das Display malen
Das ist gut
LCT Panel Draw Bitmap
Okay, Chat, wir
Wir drawen jetzt ein Bitmap
Das beste Bitmap aller Zeiten wird jetzt getrawt
und zwar auf panel panel wie geht es weiter start 0 y 0 ende 100 ende 100 jetzt brauchen wir einen
array mit pixel drin wir machen jetzt einfach random pixel wie macht man dann wie wie random
weiß man was in C++.
Wir brauchen jetzt erstmal
einen Array.
Mit
Chat.
Was brauchen wir für einen Array? Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Wir brauchen
einen Array, wobei 100 mal 100
und dann 16 Bit Farbtiefe.
Also werden wir wahrscheinlich sowas brauchen
wie 100 mal 100
mal 16.
So.
Wie macht man das denn jetzt, den C++-Way?
Kann man auf den Dingern Code testen, ohne die ständig zu flashen?
Nein.
Aber du kannst die Dinger sauer oft flashen.
Also ich habe noch nie einen kaputt geflasht.
Also was du machen kannst ist, es gibt Micro-Python dafür, da musst du nur den Interpreter draufladen.
Und den Rest kannst du dann quasi über ein Webinterface rüberschicken.
Aber nee, die musst du immer flashen.
ich habe noch nie ein kaputt geflasht
wie macht man denn jetzt ein ok data gleich standard array das
als plus plus stellt wie geht das
type name charley beit hat sie plus plus über so was wie ein beid typ ja weit
standard beid was das für ein komisches zeug schon wieder was ist std beid warum
Ist Byte nicht einfach ein normaler Datentyp?
Concept of a Byte?
Specified in a C...
Okay, Leute, das Konzept eines Bytes
ist anscheinend unterschiedlich.
Das muss die C++ Language Definition sagen,
was ein Byte ist.
U in Pixel Data.
Höhe, Breite.
Ja.
Nee, warte mal.
Ich hab eine Idee.
Wir machen jetzt sowas hier.
Wir zeroen das.
Wobei, zeroen, dann sieht man ja auf dem Display nichts.
Wir randomizen das jetzt einfach.
Nee, size macht man so hier.
Okay, jetzt haben wir eine Standard...
Wie randomizt man?
Gibt es sowas wie Standard Random?
Random Shuffle.
Ne, das will ich nicht.
Äh.
Ich hätte gerne
Random
S-Rand.
Was?
Rand gibt es.
Und es gibt jetzt ein Int, oder wie?
also mache ich jetzt quasi eine vorschleife oder wie?
da kann ich ja hier dann data, length oder size oder so und dann data gleich rent
Das ist für uns natürlich nett.
Wäre ja auch zu einfach.
Achso.
Ich muss das erst noch casten.
So, standard bite.
Bite.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt den hässlichen...
Wisst ihr...
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich nicht checke.
Wer denkt wirklich,
dass das die schönere Variante ist,
zu casten?
Chat, mal ernsthaft.
Was ist ein schönerer Cast?
einfach ein stinknormal hier in klammern davor oder dieses hässliche konstrukt ja
ja ich weiß c++ macht da noch irgendeine magic dabei dass es checkt ob man das konvertieren
kann oder nicht aber ich finde das so hässlich use range space loop instead ok mach high iq c++
Nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ganz bestimmt nicht.
So, was stört ihn jetzt an dem Randomized hier?
Rant has limited randomness.
Use C++ Random Library instead.
Okay, was ist die C++11 Random Library?
Nicht, dass es irgendwie problematisch wäre.
Ich weiß, dass es mehrere Casts gibt in C++, aber ich bin zu neugierig, um zu verstehen, was die Unterschiede sind.
Ich benutze nur das C-Style Casting.
Standard Back-Inserter. Das gefällt dir, oder? Das schreibst du in jedem Stream.
In jedem Stream, Alter.
Okay.
Also.
Passt mal auf jetzt jetzt lernen wir was
Okay, das ist wieder der wettbewerb des c++ gremiums gewesen wie hässlich und umständlich kann man eine random nummer generierung machen
All da wenn ich das schon wieder sehe man
Wenn ich das schon wieder sehe
wisst ihr, wisst ihr Leute, es gibt, es gibt
Sprachen, ja, da kannst du
einfach sowas sagen, ich mach jetzt mal hier
sinngemäß, irgendwie, irgendwie, irgendwie
Beispiel machen wir jetzt einfach mal, ja
du, es gibt Sprachen, da hast du sowas
hier, math.random
int 32
oder, oder, oder, keine Ahnung, next
paddish
es geht halt einfach
Das ist zu einfach, ja.
Wir brauchen hier Random Device RD.
MT19937.
Komplett obvious, was das ist.
Ich meine, wer kennt es nicht, MT19937.
Uniform Real Distribution brauchen wir dann.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Von-Bis vermutlich.
Das Range zu nennen wäre wahrscheinlich auch zu doof.
MT-1937 waren deine ersten Worte.
Dachte ich mir.
Wem... wer nicht?
Okay, ich google das jetzt mal.
Ah.
Ein Mercine Twister Pseudo-Random Generator.
klingt also ich habe das schon mal gehört ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob das so wichtig ist wenn man einfach nur eine random nummer haben will was es
unter der haube verwendet dann beispiel für egal leute scheiß drauf wir benutzen
wir benutzen die limited randomness von standard rand ok
Range hätte zu viel Quality of Life.
Okay.
Ja, dann wollen wir mal, oder?
Okay, Chat, nochmal kurze Prediction.
Geht's jetzt?
Moment, Moment, ich hab's noch gar nicht geflasht.
Ihr könnt doch schon mal...
Kurze Prediction, zeigt das Display jetzt was an oder nicht?
Äh, achso, äh, Punkt Data vielleicht? Punkt Data?
Nein?
Ne, ja?
Hast du das gerade aus
Afterlife hast du das gleich
Gerade aus Chat-GPD rausgeholt
Ah ja
Ich muss sagen, ich fand das von Java eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Bei Java gab es irgendwie sowas wie thread local random.nextint oder sowas.
Das fand ich auch nicht verkehrt.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Flash.
Bam.
Ja, witzig.
Also man sieht, dass es durchaus Sprachen gibt, die das so easy machen können.
Achtung.
Und? Und?
Nix.
Scheiße.
Okay, wir machen irgendwas falsch, Leute.
Wir machen irgendwas falsch.
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen vielleicht noch?
Ich hab das alles so...
Ich hab das alles so gemacht,
wie der Dude hier.
Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas?
Muss ich vielleicht hier nochmal gucken.
Example, Example CPP.
Warte.
Ja, da macht er mit LVGL was.
Das kommt ja erst viel später.
Guck mal nochmal. Display.
Irgendwas mit Display.
Get.
sind nicht so mit display application cpp auf jeweils mit display vielleicht display
create set baffes set bit mir hier lässt das bild einfach anzeigen
auch mal denn da noch
du hast ja rgb format mit 60 mit das heißt er nimmt rgb 565 standard das kann gut sein aber
das ist letztendlich egal weil ich alles rennen weiße kriegt er kriege ich halt ein pixel pixel
wir war auf dem display das ist ja okay dass sie da würde ich wenigstens was sehen
okay war was anderes t display spdf not working aber einfach mal das hat mir sogar schon mal auf
das letzte mal guckt mal hier das klingt doch gut t display s3 spdf v 5.0 issue vielleicht ist es
ist irgendein bug dass er etwas kaputt ist oder so als bin pulling my hair out ja ich auch ich
auch was macht er dann lass mal kurz gucken ob wir irgendwas erkennen was der noch mal
paar rahmen war alles netz mit color was macht denn die right color
checks checks nicht
keine ahnung was er hier treibt
guckt er macht hier in dieser
color transition
dann geschichte macht er auch nix
hier hier ist das setup
also als erstes
sagt er
gpro set level
Moment!
Geht das überhaupt?
Muss ich vielleicht auch sowas hier sagen?
Muss ich vielleicht auch hier so eine
SetGPIO-Config machen?
Und kann ich einfach
SetDirection machen?
So dass das Display quasi gar nicht an ist.
Moment, das ist Backlight.
Mit Backlight mache ich doch gar nichts.
Power.
Aber das Display hat ja Power.
Ne, das Backlight hat Power.
Das Display nicht unbedingt.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ob das vielleicht da was dran ändert.
Hier, Power.
Hin.
Power.
Hinten Power.
Äh, Level.
Ja, 1.
Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funzt.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich glaube...
Was nu?
Wie viel soll ich denn da noch machen?
Make Const, Make Const Expel.
Warum kann...
Also angeblich kann Ryder das richtig sortieren.
Bei mir kann er das irgendwie nicht.
Was auch nicht.
Warum?
Okay, Flash Champ.
Und...
Geh...
Nee.
Shit.
Dann...
Okay, ich lass das aber mal so.
Das schadet ja nix.
Das schadet ja so nix.
Das ist ja ziemlich das gleiche.
Okay, weiter.
Weiter im Text.
Turn off LCD Backlight.
Initialize Intel.
der Intel 8080 Bus. Das klingt aber wirklich wie was, was man im Jahr 2025 verwenden sollte.
Ja, das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, was wir auch haben.
Clock Source.
Ja, auch gut, weiß nicht.
SRAM Transalignment.
Wollen wir das auch angeben?
Ach Moment, das ist irgendwas anderes, das brauche ich glaube ich nicht.
vermutlich hatte ich jetzt einfach mal so so dann macht er den kram hier
dci level dc cmd level
xerox sage ich würde den sub exzellente subscription
ein eilpunkt für alle im chat mehr die ziele wills die ziele level 0 dc damit
level dc data level brauche ich das überhaupt alles aber wenn habe ich ja auch drin stehen
Swap Color Bytes
Das müssen wir uns mal merken
Weil das eigentlich so gut wie immer
Abfuck ist
Hab ich das auch?
Swap Bytes?
Ne, hab ich nicht
Das merken wir uns mal
Weil ich hatte richtige Probleme mit dem alten T-Disk
Weil die Farben richtig waren
Das merken wir uns mal
das merken wir uns falls es also falls wir da farben rauskriegen so händel händel das
akuma lcd rgb indian rgb haben wir nicht aber das egal wie wir sehen ja noch gar nichts auf
dem display also ob jetzt die farben falls nicht weil ich vollkommen egal lcd panel set
Mirror, Set Gap, Log, Buffer, Timer, Create.
Das brauchen wir...
Moment.
Das haben wir nicht.
Das stand in dem anderen Beispiel nicht drin.
Was ist das?
LC, ESP, LCD Panel, Display on, off.
Okay.
Achtung.
Und.
Geht nicht.
Shit.
Das wäre auch zu schön gewesen.
Ja, was könnte das denn sein?
Äh, Moment, Leute.
Guckt mal hier.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, Data E.
ich schreibe ja gar nichts aufs display warum geht das nett jedoch moment chat
sofort range macht das überhaupt sinn ich schreibe da was rein wie macht man
okay warte mal sp random sp hat doch bestimmt irgendwie random number
generate viel random klingt doch schon mal gut
phil random esp beste beste wir haben immer alles dabei was man braucht
excellent da machen wir das ganze misst nämlich vorweg sagen phil random kein
standard array sondern wir machen jetzt die old school variante malock
size 100 x 100 x 16 und jetzt filmen wir einfach das da mit size of dem da so jetzt
habe ich hier random zeug drin viel besser als komisches t++ randomize du hast recht wobei wir
Wir restarten hier eh danach.
Wir können uns das free eigentlich...
Ja, aber du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Free.
Nicht das, was wir wirklich brauchen würden an der Stelle.
So.
Pogge, Pogge, Pogge.
Pogge, Pogge, Pogge, Pogge.
Ha!
Was ist das?
Es macht was.
Extremely Pock, würde ich sagen.
Chat!
Jetzt macht das Sinn!
jetzt macht das sinn jetzt verstehe ich das ich habe gestern nämlich auch
darum gebastelt und ich hab's ums verrecken nicht hingekriegt aber was ich
gestern gemacht habe ist ich habe ich habe das hier genommen und habe gesagt
mach mal mach mal 100 100 kästchen von 0 bis 100 von 100 bis von 100 bis 100 von
100 bis 200 und von 200 bis...
Ach, keine Ahnung, was ich angegeben habe.
Und es hat ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Das hat gefehlt.
Von meinem Gebastel kommt nämlich hier noch
der rote... oder was auch immer das da in der Mitte...
Das soll rot sein, ne?
Da kommt ja noch dieses rote Ding in der Mitte.
Das ist...
Das habe ich gestern da schon reingeschrieben.
Das ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen heute noch im RAM.
Wie geht denn sowas?
Warum ist das heute noch im Speicher drin?
Was haben die China-Chinesen denn da wieder gebaut?
LCD-Panel-Display-On.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Die ganzen Beispiele
Die können ja alle nicht funktioniert haben
Die hier und so, die haben nirgends wo
Passt mal auf, lasst uns mal suchen, kurz nach
Ach hier kann man wieder nicht richtig drin suchen
Weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin, gell
Code kann man ja nicht suchen, da muss man einloggen
Wartet mal, das interessiert mich jetzt
Die Beispiele können doch überhaupt nicht funktionieren
Sonst
TMP, Git, Clone
klinik klinik klinik
grepp
gibt es da drin die beispiele funktionieren alle nicht das muss da rein
hier sp lcd panel display on off ja dann
dann kann man nur sagen mindset es war
aber nicht easy so wie schreiben random
Sachen rein. Äh, Moment.
Chat. Chat. Chat.
Moment.
Da stimmt was nicht.
Warum
sind dort
noch random Sachen?
Warum sind noch
random Sachen von gestern drin?
Ich schreib hier... Ah, nicht random.
Warum sind noch Kästchen von gestern
drin? Ich schreib doch gar nix.
Ich schreib doch random
da rein.
Ah, Moment. 100x100.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Breite.
Hallo? C-Line?
Hallo? IDE?
Please, kannst du funktionieren?
Breite.
LCD-Höhe.
Alter, meine IDE kackt voll ab.
Es hat einfach keinen Bock auf C++.
170 mal 300...
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
320 mal 170.
Anzeige, Chatbrains.
So, jetzt malen wir das ganze Display voll mit Gedöns.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, was jetzt?
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich nicht so viel Speicher habe?
Wäre das möglich?
Aber Reset sollte das Display doch eigentlich leer machen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das macht keinen Sinn, das funktioniert.
Da ist noch der aus irgendwelchen gründen der speicher folgende sachen von gestern im display gespeichert
Ja so viel speicher habe ich nicht leute glaube ich ob das das problem
habe nicht genug speicher
nicht genug
Aber...
Also seht ihr Leute, hier unten...
Guckt mal.
Hier unten...
Hat er random das reingeschrieben.
Aber hier ist noch das alte.
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Da stimmt doch irgendwas ganz heftig nicht.
Okay, wir machen mal was anderes.
Ist überhaupt mal 16?
Size of
Uint16, müsste doch das gleiche sein, oder?
Anzeige
wobbelt auch leicht.
Ja, ne, das liegt an der Kamera, die Spack drum.
Also,
Aber irgendwas überträgt der?
Ja, ja, schon. Ja, so ist das nicht.
Ich glaube, du kannst den Code klauen.
Okay, Chat.
Können wir vielleicht mal 200 mal 200 machen?
Ich meine, das ist out of bounds,
aber das sollte den doch nicht stören, oder?
Aha, guck dir mal da
Jetzt hat er
Jetzt hat er hier oben
Random
200x200
Nicht so wirklich
Aber er hat auf jeden Fall
Irgendwas gemacht
Das Display macht mich fertig
Wartet mal, vielleicht sollten wir mal was anderes machen
Wir tun jetzt mal einfach so, als würde es funktionieren
Chat, ich muss mal nebenbei noch ein Brötchen futtern
Ja, Pimpo, fett
Okay
Wir tun jetzt mal so
Als würde alles super funktionieren, okay
Dann probiere ich nochmal das
Was ich gestern schon probiert habe
Was aus irgendwelchen Gründen das Sachen
Richtig in den Rahmen geschrieben hat
Also, was ich gestern probiert habe ist folgendes
Ich habe eine Funktion gemacht
SetColor
So.
Die hat an Optionen gekriegt.
Wobei, ich mach das hier oben einfach.
Ist hier gefreeet.
So.
Also hier.
Void, Set Color.
Oder schreibt man das klein.
Set Color.
Die kriegt ein U in 16.
Das ist die Farbe. Color.
Dann X
und ein Y, wo es hin soll.
So.
Vielleicht sollte man
dem das vielleicht auch noch immer dann habe ich gesagt wir brauchen mit dem
richtigen sei es auch sollte jetzt geht es kann sein dass wir gar nicht das
komplette bild mit der gesamten farb die wir überhaupt in den ramm kriegen das
kann durchaus sein es kann es kann sein dass man mehrere
tron aufrufe braucht an unterschiedlichen koordinaten um
komplettes bild zu malen
ok dann habe ich gesagt data gleich
Warte mal, nee, nee, nee, ich weiß wie ich es gemacht habe.
Ich habe es mir zeroed, habe ich es mir geholt.
Ja, so.
Und dann habe ich gesagt 170 mal 320.
170 mal 320.
das ganze sei es auf 16 so habe ich das in 16 so habe ich das gemacht genau so data haben wir
jetzt was will er jetzt was hat er für schmerzen value ist never you können das ganze noch karsten
Was ist denn nur mit Cast? Los.
So.
Okay, Static Cast, meinetwegen.
Wenn es C++ so will.
So, dann machen wir eine Schleife.
Du hast recht.
Laurin, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Nicht mal 16.
Sind ja keine 16 Bytes.
Der 2 Byte
Du hast recht
Ich hab Blödsinn
Ich hab Blödsinn gemacht
Chat wieder
Sieht man es mal wieder
Die vielen Subs bringen was
Der Chat ist mittlerweile so high IQ
Ich könnte eigentlich den Chat
Ich könnte den Chat Access quasi
Zu meinem Editor geben und die würden das machen
Easy würden die das machen
Aber komm nicht auf die Idee
Dass ich euch wirklich Access zu meinem Editor gebe
Weil ich weiß, das erste ist, was passiert...
Wisst ihr, was das erste ist, was passieren
wird? Würde, wenn ich euch Zugang
zu meinem Editor geben würde, dann würde
auf einmal der Chainlaw im Chat spawnen
und irgendwie eins von seinen komischen
ASCII-Dickpicks posten.
120 mal
mal 320?
Wollen wir eine Schleife machen?
Wo ist der Chainlaw eigentlich?
ewig nix mal, war ja nicht mal am Start hier.
Und jetzt sagen wir Data.
Data.
I
gleich
Color.
So. Ha.
Pog.
Ja gut.
Kunst. Mach's Kunst.
Data.
I gleich Color.
Jetzt muss ich aber auf jeden Fall
Okay. Und jetzt muss
das erst mal
Callen. Dann machen wir mal
einen Delay rein. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
es... Wir machen da mal
einen Delay rein.
Und danach sagen wir Free Data.
So.
Und jetzt können wir mal
farben.
Ah ne, Moment. Eins brauchen wir
noch.
Wir wollen es von 100.
Ne, warte mal.
Wir wollen das von Start X, Y und dann hier X plus 100 und Y plus 100.
So wollen wir das machen.
So, und jetzt können wir mal eine Farbe suchen, ob das funzt.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Set Color.
Jetzt brauchen wir 16-Bit-Color-Picker.
Da gibt es bestimmt einen schöneren, oder?
gent gent gent da einer gent sane guten
Ja genau.
Okay.
Printline.
Red.
Wir starten.
An 0.
Slash 0.
Moment.
0x, ne?
So.
Rot. Das reicht jetzt erstmal.
Mehr machen wir mal noch nicht.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Da ist irgendwas
rotes
an der Ecke erscheint.
Oben links müsste jetzt was rotes erscheinen.
Äh.
Es erscheint
was blaues unten rechts.
Das ist ja schon mal nicht ganz verkehrt.
Ich hab zwar gesagt, es erscheint was Rotes oben links
und es erscheint was Blaues unten rechts,
aber immerhin erscheint schon mal was Viereckiges.
Das liegt bestimmt an irgendwelchen RGB-Sortierungsdingern.
aber warum sind wir eigentlich unten rechts swap xy das ist glaube ich nicht
das problem das ist weil ich im querformat habe
in word color
Chat, warum ist 00 unten rechts?
Moment!
Ich bin ja dumm.
00 ist nicht unten rechts.
00 ist oben links.
Ich habe das Display einfach falsch rumliegen.
F800 wäre rot?
Hä?
Warum sagt er mir hier dann, das ist...
Ist das...
Ist das Shit, was die da schreiben?
Falsche RGB-Space.
Das ist grausam.
16-Bit-Color-Picker.
Uah!
Ich will erstmal, dass oben links, oben links ist, okay?
und ich will sicher sein dass wir rot auch wirklich rot genommen haben
kann man so was wie rotate machen hier mirror haben wir? ah moment
mirror x
warte mal wenn ich das beides mirrore
Oder soll ich das mal auf Fall stellen, was dann passiert?
Den hatte ich doch eben schon.
Den hatte ich doch eben.
Ne, ne, das ist ein anderer.
Okay, ähm.
Also, 0.
Du hast recht.
Das andere Ding ist einfach Schrott.
Chat, jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt.
Ist irgendwas passiert?
Ach, das andere ist kein 565 RGB.
Aha.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir die blaue Kiste und links.
Obwohl sie eigentlich rot sein sollte.
Aber okay.
Unten links.
Unten links ist schon mal gut.
So.
Und jetzt machen wir Mirror X.
Und jetzt ist 0.
0 auch oben links.
Pass auf.
Es ist oben links.
Bam.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich wenigstens,
dass 0 0 oben links ist.
Aber seht ihr, der merkt sich die Dinger irgendwie.
Der muss das irgendwo gespeichert haben.
Du musst Clear Screen machen.
Das ist korrekt.
Guck mal mal. LCD Clear.
Gibt es aber nicht.
Ich mache hier schon Reset.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das cleart.
Zugang Zugang
Gell?
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Wie könntest du wirklich selbst machen?
Wie könntest du...
Wie könntest du selbst clearen?
da können wir einfach schwarz also quasi einfach mal zero das ist ein kompletten screen
war noch mal
mal hier start x
x
oder
der hintergrund schwarz 170 120 schwarz ist 000
so vermutlich bin ich bis zum max ein spiel wo bloß viele nullen und aber fast
Guck mal, Leute.
Die Hälfte.
Ich habe Höhe und Breite vertauscht.
Höhe und Breite sind vertauscht.
Null ist null.
Zack.
Es ist gecleart, Leute.
Easy.
easy easy easy easy easy so wir haben unseren screen gecleart so jetzt kann man das mit den
farben machen also jetzt machen wir rot so eine rote farbe das war 0
ihr habt recht das sind nur vier wobei eigentlich ist das auch genau das gleiche 0 ist 0 oder
die farbe ist auch falsch wegen dem swap color das kann sehr gut sein das kann sehr gut sein
sein dass es daran liegt so red dann moment aber das nur 100 nur 100er
kästchen ja 100 so jetzt brauchen wir grün
grün, zack, von 100 bis 0, 100 breit, 100 und jetzt nochmal für blau
0 irgendwas f und das jetzt von 200 sondern jetzt sollten wir eigentlich drei kästchen
kriegen links oben ein rotes dann ein grünes und dann im blaues schau mal die farben werden
die stimme aber immerhin klima drei kästchen wir kriegen drei kästchen das erkennt man nicht
richtig das ist weil irgendwie die kamera ziemlich sagt das ist grün das
ist blau das ist rot das ist grün das stimmt aber hinten und vorne nicht in
der mitte sollte immer grün sein egal ob bgr oder rgb
warum ist in der mitte nicht grün warum ist rechtsgrün
Was ist denn, wenn ich hier Flash anwache?
Aha, guckt mal.
So ist besser, oder, Leute?
Jetzt erkennt man wenigstens die Farben besser.
Okay, also.
wir gucken mal was passiert wenn ich in word color weg machen
ja ja das mit dem job kohler das probleme klaus eins nach dem anderen
achtung okay das jetzt ganz was anderes
Das ist jetzt ganz was anderes.
Das ist jetzt hellgelb, hellgrün und irgendwie purple.
Ey, vorher waren die Farben wenigstens richtig, Mann.
Okay, Invert Color muss auf jeden Fall an.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Also du meinst hier RGB, BGR machen wir jetzt.
Aber BGR kann es ja nicht sein.
Weil in der Mitte müsste immer grün sein.
Okay, BGR.
Rot, blau, grün.
Es müsste rot...
Moment.
Ja, es müsste rot, grün, blau sein.
Rot oben links stimmt aber immerhin schon mal.
Okay, ich mache RGB wieder hier hin.
Und jetzt machen wir hier
Blacks.
Ja, der hat das gemacht, der Typ hier.
Eins.
gibt's kann das bei sbg haben doch ausprobiert
hoch was jetzt
alles geht mir so auf den sack wo muss das jetzt hin
so geht's
Okay, Achtung.
Rot!
Rot, grün, blau!
Es ist richtig!
Magic Swap Bytes gleich 1.
Der Swapped
Swap
Adjacent to Color Bytes.
Also der Swap
dann quasi rot mit grün, oder was?
Easy!
Obviously muss das so sein.
Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy
jetzt grb wegen dem zwar also übertragen wird grb aber wir können rgb einfach in rgb verwenden
ja da muss man mal schauen
mal kurz mein apfel futter aber immerhin als fuß
wir hoffen einfach mal als funst
die farben wären wahrscheinlich wurst gewesen rein für den qr code aber es trotzdem blöd
nicht zu wissen ob die farben richtig oder wie man es macht so display funst
nein zu
der kurs ist 18 uhr 20
jetzt habe ich zwei stunden rum gemacht nur überhaupt das backlight anzukriegen
was haben wir denn sonst noch hier ist irgendwas was man vielleicht auch
rausschmeißen sollten was macht ein set gap noch weiteres ziel geht in den sprint okay
da vielleicht kriegen wir was gemalt auf das display
ich weiß nicht warum wir irgendwelche gaps setzen aber okay
immerhin ist funst übrigens das stand auch nicht in dem beispiel trainer
spot bites ja das beispiel kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren
omega ludel
ja ich verstehe es auch nicht wenn sich freiwillig ziel plus plus gibt das ding
ist halt dass sp 32 lässt sich halt oder der sp 32 immer noch am besten ziel plus
programmieren ist sehr schön aber manchmal muss man auch was ekliges machen
ich hab' ich hab' eine idee
Ich hab eine Idee.
Können wir daraus
nicht
mit FFmpeg
einen Bitmap erzeugen
Mit 16 bit Farbtiefe oder wie auch immer man das nennt
Und dann das ganze in den C-Array umwandeln und das dann dahin schreiben
Text
Das machen wir mit LVGL dann alles
vgl ist so eine kraft ex library aber ich fürchte für lv gl reicht heute die zeit nicht aus
hammer mit ffm pack mit map
wie ist dieses ding rgb 565
fm pack fm pack kann einfach mal wieder alles
monka es alter was
Okay.
Moment mal.
Also, Input.
Anime Excited.
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz
einen neuen Ordner.
Fuck.
Excited.
Ah, ja, ja.
Die FFM Pack.
Filter, Komplex, Scale.
Ey, kein Blassenschimmer.
Das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert.
okay wir machen das wir machen das mal anders wir erzeugen uns wir erzeugen uns
einfach nur daraus ein blut punkt bmp
okay after life hat chat gpt gefragt probieren wir aus ob chat gpt recht hat
jet gpd recht
ok man war club bmp habe ich jetzt schon erzeugt geht nicht also ff play
okay das ist ein
was war das eine ff probe
Was ist denn das hier?
F-Play? Frame?
Ne
Das
Das vonst nicht, was du geschickt hast
Okay, ich bin jetzt so blöd,
sowas draus zu erzeugen, Alter.
FF Play.
Macht der jetzt was?
Nee, oder?
Aber wenn das ein Bitmap ist, kann ich das nicht in Chroma zeigen?
Äh, nein.
Nicht.
Okay, das funzt.
Okay, Blub BMP. Blub BMP ist es.
Okay, also.
Sekunde, brauche ich doch mal hier mal
ein langes Ding. Blub.
Blub BMP.
Ich will es, ich will eigentlich gar nichts
mit FPS machen.
Eigentlich will ich nur Format machen.
Geht das so?
oh man hat gpd ich war auch mal auf deutsch ich habe ein bitmap bild und
will das mit ffm pack in ein rgb 565 bitmap konzertieren
Okay, aber das haben wir nicht. Guck mal hier.
Klopp.
So, jetzt haben wir hier
output.RGB
Das kann FFmpeg aber nicht anzeigen, oder?
Das ist einfach nur quasi die RAW Daten sozusagen.
sagen das heißt jetzt kann ich sagen wie war das noch mal sachen in den cr konvertieren convert
data to see reynaux das war doch irgendwie so lb oder irgendwie sowas xxd xxd xd hd
Was ist Minus I?
Include.
Okay.
Cut.
Output.
Aber Afterlife, das müsste jetzt so auch funktionieren, oder?
Wie ich das gemacht habe.
Output.
Punkt RGB.
XXD minus I.
Da haben wir es.
Äh.
Chat.
Sollte das nicht eigentlich...
sollte da nicht jetzt irgendwie noch was davor stehen xxd ich habe das doch schon mal verwendet
hier
KQI.
Moment, minus I ist...
Minus I Output RGB.
Aha, schon besser.
Okay.
Nice.
Excellent.
Okay, jetzt haben wir das Bild.
Das Bild.
Jetzt mache ich eine extra Datei.
Was ist das von mir?
Äh, Image.
Zack.
einfach mal 8000 Zeilen
hoffentlich reicht mein RAM von dem Ding aus
okay
machen wir das mal weg
und jetzt
ESP LCD
Draw Bitmap.
0, 0.
Ähm, ja.
170.
Ne, Moment.
120, 170.
Und jetzt
Output.
Out.
Stimmt!
Wir hätten das vorher konvertieren sollen.
Unser Bild ist ja zu groß, ne?
Egal, das können wir immer noch machen.
Output.
äh,
Output RGB.
Was jetzt?
Achso, Panel muss dann auch vorne hin.
Okay, zack.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das Funst, äh,
ob da jetzt ein eier jahr bild gleich raus kommt oder random pixel
random pixel
ich weiß ja nicht
ich würde sagen das hat nicht funktioniert
funktioniert.
Line breaks?
Welche Line breaks?
Das ist ein Byte Array, da ist nichts mit Line breaks.
Nee, das ist, das ist, das ist ein Byte Array, das ist quasi so ein zweidimensionales Bild
da drinne.
Also erste Zeile sind die Bytes für, würde ich mal sagen, oder?
Erste Zeile sind die Bytes für...
Achso, vielleicht sollten wir es echt nochmal kopieren.
Warte mal, vielleicht konvertieren wir das doch nochmal kurz.
ffmpeg Resize Image hier, 4f Scale
Beste, ich brauch mal
ffmpeg
Ups, ffmpeg
und jetzt hier noch Scale vorher
320 x 170 ist das chat ist das höhe oder was ist das höhe oder seitenverhältnis falsch
was war das habe ich da gerade gesehen
es sind da die weeps unter uns hier bei ffm pack
nämlich gimp ffm pack
ich habe eine bessere idee ich habe eine bessere idee
wir stellen auf 100 100
wobei das Bild ist in 200x200
dann weiß ich was wir machen
dann schreiben wir 200
220x220 hier hin
dann sollte er das nämlich
dann malt er halt über das Bild
rüber raus
aber es müsste eben Seitenverhältnis stimmen
aber ich glaube unsere Pixeldaten sind nicht ganz korrekt
Leute!
Da ist es!
Es geht einfach.
Kaum macht man die Größe richtig.
kaum stellt man die größe richtig ein easy wisst ihr was das sieht richtig gut aus auf dem display
also von den farben her und so merkt man dass es ein ordentliches ist ein kleines display ist
ein adblocker
Ja.
Genau, den Rest hat er wieder oben drüber geschrieben.
Das sieht gut aus.
Ja.
Kannst nichts sagen.
Leute, ich würde sagen,
das Display funzt.
Das war nicht ganz so easy,
aber nachdem wir heute das C++ High Performer Grindset Mindset haben,
muss man einfach an sich glauben
und in die Gruppe kommen.
Dann ist alles easy.
Easy.
Du kannst, was sagen die immer?
Du kannst alles schaffen und so Zeug.
Ich erzähle doch die ganzen Guru-Leute da immer.
Wie war das? Willst du nicht?
Dann helfen wir dir. Kannst du nicht?
Ne, wie ging das?
Das ist ein dummer Spruch, Alter.
ich muss noch jemand kurz etwas kleines fertig futtern
ich futter schon eine stunde an einem brötchen und einem stück Toastbrot
Ein Fiat 500 Beste.
Ich freue mich, dass das so gut funktioniert hat.
Man muss einfach manchmal nur hartnäckig sein.
ich habe heute mittag genug gefordert aber mittag ein schnitzelbrötchen
gegessen salami brötchen und eine appel ecke und die brötchen waren groß
kann man nichts warmes gegessen aber muss man auch nicht jeden tag
besser für peter fett time
Alter mein Handy, Leute. Mein Handy glüht fast, weil ich nehme es hier oben gerade mit dem Handy auf.
Ich habe keinen Bock die Kamera dahin zu stellen an der Stelle. Das rennt sich gleich durch die
unterlage durch so heißt ist das das ist ja wirklich ein guter zeitpunkt einfach
für heute mal schluss zu machen kann ich mich auch in ruhe mein toastbrot
futter und wir sehen uns im nächsten stream leute
ja klein sein mindset wir haben genug gekleidet für heute machen wir dann
machen wir auch ja machen wir auch leute wir sehen uns im nächsten schrieb
macht's gut bis denn